red telephone boxes like this one are an
icon of britain
or well they were nowadays the boxes
that are left are falling into disrepair
and ruined because there's not much
demand for pay phones these days
if a little village wants to save theirs
then the phone company will sell it to
them for one pound enough to make the
contract legal and binding but
they won't keep the phone connected so
what do you do with a disused phone box
well one of the options being installed
right here might help to save lives
community album trust is currently the
the leading organization for the
provision of community defibrillators in
the uk
today we've probably positioned six and
a half thousand community defibrillators
or thereabouts
it costs somewhere between around
sixteen hundred pounds and two thousand
two hundred depending on the equipment
it turns out the logistics aren't quite
as simple as buy a defibrillator and
stick it in a box
a defibrillator is a medical device if
it's poorly maintained or it breaks
then it could be worse than useless it
could actually do harm
there's no use just putting it in and
then forgetting about it these need to
be looked after and it's got to be as
good in
several years time as it is on day one
and it's going to be sustainable
it's not just about raising funds
initially it's also about ongoing costs
and on ongoing fundraising to make sure
that this is actually looked after for
the entire life that it's going to be in
the community
the first thing we need to find out from
the process is you know is the kiosk
actually available they can't
decommission it unless there's a
mobile phone signal for emergencies when
the community contacts us we'll let the
local ambulance service know
that a default rate is going in and then
it's available in an emergency when
somebody phones 999
the ambulance service will be able to
say there is a defibrillator it's
located at the phone box on the corner
of x and y roads
and if the cabinet is locked they'll
give an access code once the
defibrillator is used you just take out
the old pads
put on new ones run a self-check to make
sure the default places are working
properly
and then it's ready for action again and
there's another question who pays for
the power
the box is connected to the national
grid so the light and the phone could
work back when it was an actual phone
box but
it doesn't have an electricity meter
it's never needed one the electricity is
there to
provide electricity for the cabinet
because there's a heater in the cabinet
it's not for the defibrillator the
defibrillators will work off batteries
and the
the heater in the cabinet obviously
keeps the defibrillator above freezing
in cold weather that's really quite
important because
batteries do degrade in cold weather the
electrodes are water gel so they will
freeze
british telecom who's the major phone
company in the uk are the people who
actually originally owned these
it actually cost bt money to take out
the electricity
so they would rather leave the
electricity in what they do with us is
they donate that to us as a charity and
then we provide the electricity to the
community so the estimated cost for a
kiosk to run it for a year is about five
to
ten pounds all of this might sound good
in theory but the question is could a
bystander
with no medical training actually use
one of these to save a life
to answer that i've come to the
headquarters of the east of england
ambulance service who are going to let
me try their training defibrillator it
doesn't actually produce a shock we just
need to use it on a dummy
but it is as realistic as simulation as
it's possible to get
so here's the story someone has
collapsed someone else is doing cpr and
i've been sent by the emergency operator
to get this so the very first thing you
do is turn it on and
listen to the voice prompts it will tell
you to follow it calmly which is a
really important thing to do so we
assume
there's someone here doing cpr
and now i have to take this
on off call emergency medical services
now okay we've done that adult mode yes
follow the voice prompt calmly okay
removal clothing from chest and stomach
it's really important that all of the
clothing is removed
and we want a bare chest there are
concerns over
maintaining dignity life comes before
dignity take out the pads from the
bottom of the device okay
the next thing it will ask you is to
apply the pads to the chest so the first
pad
you're going to put on the patient's
right shoulder the second pad you're
going to put just below their left
armpit
just peel off the pads labeled two
and stick to the bare skin of the
patient exactly as shown
in the picture in the picture just below
there
okay do not touch the patient
analyzing heart rhythm at this point it
will tell you not to touch the patient
and that's really important it's going
to be analyzing that heart rhythm
one of the ones it's going to be looking
for is where the heart is just wobbling
around where there's no regularity to it
and it's not able to pump blood
what it needs to do then is stop that
heart with an electric shock
once it stopped it the natural pacemaker
of the heart
can kick back in and put the heart back
into a normal rhythm where it can pump
blood
shock advised okay stand
clear press the flashing orange button
now
shock delivered begin
cpr now if they are in
a rhythm that the aed can shock it will
increase
their chance of survival about 10 per
minute
re-analyzing heart rhythm in one minute
so i've arrived at a call where there is
a defib it has been used and it's been
used successfully
and the patient has started breathing
again prior to my arrival
analyzing heart rhythm it is the
human equivalent of turning someone off
then on again shock
advised if you haven't had any formal
training you can still use a
defibrillator you shouldn't be prevented
from
doing it but you should be trained in
order to get the most efficient usage of
that equipment
so i assume this would continue until
emergency services actually arrive
so yes once we arrive we'll take over
what you're doing we'll attach our
defibrillator
and take over management of the patient
i realized when it said start cpr
that i don't actually know about that i
only know what i've picked up from
media so i'm hoping i was vaguely in the
right position then yep
absolutely i need to go do proper first
aid training
thank you ideally it could have done
with just being up a bit
on the shoulder rather than there but
you know that would have worked that
would work the main thing is that would
have done the job
right now you know you're in the center
of the chest there doing the chest
compressions right
speed it's fine you would have saved
their life if if it was savable you
would have done it
which is all that matters thank you very
much